salut aujourd'hui j'ai une tête de
malades parce que je suis malade et on
pourrait même dire que j'ai une tête de
zombie oui mais les zombies ça n'existe
pas si ça existe c'est pas tout à fait
comme on l'entend mais il ya une
explication rationnelle au fait que les
zombies existe vraiment et d'où vient
cette légende générique tout pour les
haïtiens et haïtiennes le vaudou ça
existe réellement nous en europe en
attendant ça pas trop y croire parce que
on associe sa de la magie noire mais en
fait les premiers vaudou ce qui existe
est peut-être que ça existe toujours
aujourd'hui ressemblait plus à une
planification d' esclavagisme qu'à un
rituel vaudou
c'est wade davis qui était chercheur au
muséum d'histoire naturelle de new york
qui a mené toute une enquête là-dessus
il était un peu passionné tout ça est un
jour il ya un haïtien qui est mort qui
s'appelait narcisse et qui apparaît
quelques jours après ça lui a permis de
creuser le sujet de faire une enquête
là-dessus de publier sans 1987 et
aujourd'hui ça nous permet à nous de
mieux comprendre comment là bas on
arrivait à fabriquer des ongles ce cher
narcisse meurt donc c'est un haïtien il
décède et se réveille à un moment donné
dans un cercueil sous la terre
complètement paralysé il entendait du
bruit au dessus on le des terres hélas
un sorcier vaudou qu'il des terres qui
lui explique qui lui a rendu la vie
grâce à un rituel vaudou lui fait
prendre une petite boisson une petite
potion pour qu'il aille beaucoup mieux
et narcisse se retrouve un petit peu un
petit peu dans le brouillard mais en
tout cas envie en train de bouger et il
doit la vie aux sorciers le sorcier
l'envoi à la plantation pour travailler
gratuitement pour lui plutôt malin
sorciers en le menaçant que toute
manière s'il ne s'exécute pas ci fais
pas le travail
alors il le reprendra la vie qui lui a
rendu est plutôt malin quand même à
cette époque permet il avait quand même
une bonne stratégie du travail pour moi
et je prends un bon pourcentage 100%
en fait au cours de son enquête wade
davis a pu approcher de très près des
potions en fait il permet tait de rendre
la personne morte ou simili mortes et de
la réveiller et il s'est aperçu qu'au
milieu toutes les plantes l'ingrédient
principal c'était le fond google le
poisson globe c'est le poison qui est
dans le poisson globe qu'on prépare dans
les restaurants et d'ailleurs qui malgré
tout une quinzaine de personnes par an
tellement le poison je crois qu'il est
il est vingt ou cinquante fois plus fort
que le cyanure
je ne sais pas le chiffrer exactement
mais il est beaucoup plus fort que le
cyanure bon et surtout il contient une
neurotoxine hépatique donc
un dosé dans le savant mélange ça
permettait de rendre une personne pas
décédé mais comme si elle était décédée
qu'un médecin puisse constater le décès
puisque deux meilleurs elle était
inconsciente paralysé et c'est pour
pouvoir la réveiller plus tard il
préparait tout une potion avec ceux
présents là il dosait ça il en faisait
une poudre qui mettait dans les
chaussures directement de la personne
qui le visaient et comme sa part avec la
transpiration et c'est ça passait par
les pores de la peau s'infiltrer dans le
sens et on croyait juste à un décès
complètement classique
ensuite le sort ciel et à la tempe il
déterrait la personne qui avait repris
conscience mais qui était toujours un
peu paralysé lui faisait le boire une
potion qui est à la base du duboisy ya
alors le dubois zia c'est une plante de
la famille de la datura qu'on trouve
dans les jardins français d'ailleurs et
cette plante est bourré d'atropine et de
scopolamine ce qui en fait un antidote
naturel du poison du poisson globe du
poison du poisson globe c'est pas si
simple à dire on a en plus découvert
récemment qu'ils avaient un peptide à
l'intérieur c'est un ensemble d'acides
aminés on va dire qui fait un peu
flanche ir la mémoire et qui a tendance
à rendre la personne un peu plus docile
le sorcier vous avez donc boire ça parce
que ça faisait un antidote et ça rendait
la personne un petit peu smooth
aujourd'hui on sait tout ça parce que
narcisse était échappé de la plantation
et saissac a mis la puce à l'oreille
dans les années 80 à wade davis qui en
plus a eu la chance d'avoir un contact
avec un enquêteur qui lui savait qu'elle
était le remède de ce poison voilà donc
à quoi servez ce rituel vaudou
en fait ça servait simplement à créer
des esclaves qu'ils allaient travailler
dans les plantations et en faisant
passer sa part de la magie eux mêmes
après n'osais pas contredire le sorcier
et vous l'avez compris c'était le
dernier hors sujet également de cette
année mais comme j'ai une tête et une
voix de son bi aujourd'hui je me suis
dit que c'était tout à fait approprié et
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo penser à
la ligue et à vous abonner si elle vous
a plu rendez vous demain à 17 heures
charlie
[Musique]